[Music]  the youngest bar brother is finally here  and he goes by the name of lamelo ball  from chino hills the good old charlotte  north carolina  he's done it his way nothing traditional  but true to who he is  [Applause]  there is nothing quiet about his game  you know when he got the bomb  okay he plays with pace and ease always  in control  never in the rush the handle stays on  the stream his vision  is unique he sees center stage and  picked up a few passport stamps along  the way  left his mark in lithuania the youngest  american professional basketball player  ever at the age of 16. he said no to  college  and yes to the pro rock so australia was  i'm laying them down and he's getting  disappointed  took home rookie of the year and it all  led him back home  he's 19 now braces off haircut  different and his own man  the mellow ball one on one